monsieur le rapporteur dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur pierre charon pour le groupe
ump
madame la présidente danoise ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues je vais commencer par un
compliment cette proposition de loi est
absolument nécessaire
il existe depuis la loi du 22 juillet
2009 de développement et de
modernisation des services touristiques
un problème évident de rationalisation
de l'offre de transport léger de
personnes ce texte doit garantir le bon
développement des taxis et des véhicules
de tourisme avec chauffeur et assurer
une juste concurrence entre les deux
acteurs cette proposition de loi a été
discutée à l'assemblée nationale le 10
juillet dernier après engagement de la
procédure accélérée l'urgence ne doit
pas mener à la précipitation car malgré
l'adoption d'amendements nombreux le
texte est encore loin d'être parfait et
s'avère sur plusieurs points majeurs
trop contraignant et voilà que pour des
raisons de circonstance le gouvernement
voudrait faire adopter le texte sans
modification donc sans vrai débat
pourquoi le scénar lancerait-il à son
rôle de législateur en adoptant conforme
un texte rédigé uniquement à l'assemblée
nationale ce texte s'ouvre de
dispositions particulièrement les
favorable à l'esprit d'entreprise et les
contraire au développement de l'emploi
et le l'initiative individuelle alors
que dans le même temps le gouvernement a
la prétention de redresser la situation
économique
ce texte doit permettre de pacifier les
relations entre les vtc et les taxis de
les finir durablement des règles de
concurrence juste entre les deux acteurs
une loi écrite trop vite qui ne
satisfait aucune des parties prenantes
ne peut être vu comme une bonne solution
en outre rien justifier l'urgence d'une
adoption définitive avant la fin notre
session puisque toutes les mesures du
texte son temps l'application pour mars
le débat ne peut se limiter à une
opposition entre des professions
réglementées
qui refuserait de s'adapter et
obtiendrait gain de cause
pour éviter la concurrence de ceux qui
se sont lancés dans de nouveaux moyens
de consommation
il ya chez la majorité des taxis une
réelle volonté de se moderniser et de
s'adapter aux demandes des consommateurs
il n'y a pas de tort pour l'une ou
l'autre des professions il faut faire en
sorte qu'elles puissent cohabiter
justement toujours au bénéfice des
consommateurs
si la concurrence déloyale eu certaines
sociétés de vtc étrangères existe il
faut l'éviter faire en sorte qu'ils
appliquent la loi
la stigmatisation de certains doit pas
faire oublier les développeurs français
vertueux comme le cap stade car
chauffeur privé à l'ocab ou super chatel
la liberté d'entreprendre doit être
préservée avant tout si les vtc dispose
effectivement d'outils électroniques et
d'une réglementation qui leur confère un
avantage concurrentiel indéniable sur
les taxis ces derniers ne semblent pas
s'être adapté a si rapidement à l'ère
numérique
le groupe ump et donc en accord avec les
auteurs du texte sur ce qui concerne la
modernisation de l'activité de taxi
nous sommes notamment tout à fait
favorables l'article 1er vous avez
évoqué monsieur le rapporteur qui vise à
créer un registre de disponibilité des
taxis est article 1er bis qui doit
permettre le paiement par carte bancaire
dans les taxis mais ce texte instaure
beaucoup de règles supplémentaires de la
contrainte alors il faudrait au
contraire davantage de liberté et de
flexibilité
si les dispositions à l'égard des taxis
sont généralement au bénéfice des
consommateurs
les vtc sont malmenés par votre texte
vous voudriez tuer la profession que
vous ne vous y prendriez pas autrement
une disposition qui fait débat au sein
même de votre gouvernement introduit une
restriction générale à la liberté
d'aller et venir des vtc et de leur
chauffeur
l'obligation faite aux vtc de rejoindre
le lieu d'établissement de leurs
exploitants ou un stationnement hors
chaussée après chaque prestation est
inacceptable cette mesure qui leur est
imposée d'une contrainte que leurs
concurrents directs sur le marché de
réservation au préalable ne subissent
pas les taxis utilisant des centrales
radio en plus de les rendre moins
efficace
la mesure entraîne pour les vtc
l'engagement de coûts supplémentaires
qui rendra leurs activités
praticable il convient de rappeler que
le conseil constitutionnel a clairement
souligné
l'anti constitutionnalité d'une
interdiction générale de stationnement
sur la voie publique pour les motos
taxis
il ya aussi cette disposition ubuesque
qui précise qu un vtc ne peux je cite
s'arrêter où stationner sur la voie
ouverte à la circulation publique
à l'abord des gares et des aérogares ou
le cas échéant dans l'enceinte de celle
ci au delà d'une durée fixée par décret
précédent
la prise en charge de clients fermez les
guillemets ce qui empêchera comble de
l'absurde de s'arrêter pour laisser
descendre son client avant d'honorer la
réservation suivante il n'est vraiment
pas raisonnable d'adopter en l'état ce
texte
en réalité cette proposition de loi
touche à des domaines variés
le pouvoir d'achat des clients pour qui
le prix est une composante essentielle
dans le choix du mode de transport
l'emploi et l'activité de notre pays
ces voies de transport constitue en
effet les premiers contacts pour les
touristes et hommes d'affaires en
déplacement mais à dire vrai la manière
avec laquelle nous traitons ce sujet et
surtout révélatrice d'une certaine
conception de la concurrence de la
liberté d'entreprendre et de
l'innovation le développement des vtc
n'a jamais été un frein à celui des
taxis ils sont même complémentaires le
développement des deux acteurs est bon
pour le développement de l'emploi et
pour les usagers
nous sommes tous ici confrontés à la
pénurie de l'offre de taxis paris a
aujourd'hui le plus mauvais ratio de
nombre de chauffeurs par habitant
inférieur même à des villes de taille
bien plus faible le contingentement du
nombre de taxis en outre empêcher toute
création d'emplois en trente ans les
deux tiers des taxis à paris fonctionne
aujourd'hui sur réservation il y à 14
milles abonnés un système de radio taxi
le sénat en sait quelque chose
il fonctionne donc essentiellement sur
réservation un tiers seulement
fonctionnent en maraude
la conséquence pour le consommateur et
la cherté de la course à londres où les
vtc se sont beaucoup développées 20% des
plus défavorisés utilisent les taxis et
minicab une fois mis le plus que 20% des
plus favorisés parce qu'ils y ont accès
les plus défavorisés utilise le taxi
plutôt que de posséder une voiture qui
leur coûterait plus cher le taxi
parisien est à ce jour un service
destiné aux plus aisés si l'offre de
transport taxis et vtc augmente les
parisiens en useront ce seront des
déplacements plus rapides et pratiques
moins de pollution et une circulation
plus fluide
il existe en france dix acteurs majeurs
du vtc qui ont environ 3500 voiture dont
50% des chauffeurs sont des
professionnels reconverti ces
entreprises créent de l'emploi et
assurer leur chauffeur une rémunération
honorable plus de 400 emplois ont été
créés par la société le cab en un an et
demi pour lui citer qu'un exemple on
peut raisonnablement estimer à 10000 les
créations d'emplois dans les cinq ans ne
nous empressons pas de tuer ce qui
marche
notre pays ne peut se le permettre pour
toutes ces raisons le groupe ump votera
contre ce texte s'il n'est pas
raisonnablement amendé je vous laisse
merci monsieur le sénateur